okay sure so it's basically a Chester
1287 all right sherry this session
friends will be speaking no introduction
I won't talk about myself okay so I'm
showing you showing it usually I show
this picture to to show people how Billy
looks but I show you this picture to see
how the mesh weather usually looks so
yeah so so this is um this is a list of
neuroscientists maybe photo verse Allah
is not known for doing for publishing in
neuroscience but he also did and this is
a it's it's kind of an incidental
observation but it's nevertheless
interesting so this group of neuro
scientists they have something in common
in their past so they all at some point
actually operated on the air so they had
kind of a station identification and it
was actually not easy to get back in the
in the day so you really needed a
permission by by that a
telecommunication ministry and so you
had to undergo an examination and so on
and but it's very hard to get a picture
of actually a real neuroscientist at the
radio station so this is King Hussein as
a stand-in and so you basically have a
small you had a small table of equipment
that you could reach every point on the
planet without any man-made
infrastructure what's a bar well thank
you I have to add to the list this is
just I found this out kind of
coincidentally somehow over the years
but yeah so so what what might actually
have shaped the way of thinking of these
people somehow and if you read david
Huber's last book he really are mentions
the open source community so he
basically said he learned
tronics from radio magazines basically
and I think this is a it's there's a
similarity here also with with
neuroscience in neuroscience you don't
have huge consumer products and numbers
we're really industry immediately kicks
in so there are things like the missus
covert Genelia and the neuro pixels and
some optical imaging techniques where
it's really an open-source hardware and
open-source community to long from each
other so that's definitely one thing and
the other thing is definitely the
communication aspect of neuroscience and
this of course has to do with brain
machine interfaces and for exam being
built bill a day here after he built his
first transmitters in Australia he built
an EEG machine but it also involves
investigating communication in the brain
and if you think of the brain doing
computations its distributed elements
communication is computation so it's
it's it's it's immensely important and
it's an aspect that I will basically
address today so Italia sorry I forgot
your suffix well you told you told me
about it's a good sign anyway so I will
talk about four projects one is the
phils to use information theory as a
tool and the last to use more ideas from
compressed sensing and sparse coding and
the first is really investigating
information transmission through an LG
and relay cell the second is then asking
how can we come up with information
measures that we can use and recurrent
networks to tell you something about
information processing and information
integration in recurrent circuits and
there was some nice progress in the last
years leading to some nice measures one
can now estimate and then I
the short felt part will tell you
something about the compressed sensing
hypothesis for cortical communication
but we put out a few years ago and this
idea also led them to a brain computer
interface idea and it led to this
decoding the phase structure in
hippocampal theta oscillations which is
a traveling wave as you have seen a lot
and you can really decode it and I think
there is not many examples here so
that's it's kind of interesting and
maybe a model how he also how we can do
more decoding so yeah information theory
actually the right picture he'll shows a
Claude Shannon with his artificial mouth
was so close chain and also was very
interested in cybernetics and actually
biology and soon after he wrote his book
in 49 there were a lot of people
thinking neuroscience in terms of
information theory and I just listed the
most important as an earlier wave early
in the cybernetics community and then
Rob the Reuter in Bill beer like really
lat kind of the analysis of of kind of
channel capacity to to new heights and
and and really did a lot of very
impactful work in the 90s also I would
like to introduce the information
geometric view of mutual information and
this is this field of information
geometry was started by Sunni Giamatti
who is also very well known to
neuroscientist he did a lot of work in
in theoretically is one of the pioneers
of theoretical neuroscience as well but
let me just describe your very quickly
so basically if you want to compute a
mutual information between two variables
X and X tilde the way you can think
about this is that you you you have a
joint probability of these two variables
and you can basically ask you can come
up with an I'll model which assumes
independence that so the Q is just of
the
a product of the marginals and now
basically all these nine models form in
general a manifold in the space of
probability distributions and you can
look for the four for basically the one
which has the minimal cool back liable
to have options and this is basically
exactly the definition of mutual
information I'm introducing this because
we will later use it for fortifying
integrated information so the in the
first project we collaborated with
judith hush who does these recordings in
thalamic cells were basically in vivo
she patches onto a single column excel
and recalls intracellularly from that
cell and you get kind of recording
traces like this so the spikes are
warping in huge but you can also see
here these smaller things and in these
these and i should also say that this is
bought by Xinhua who was a student a PhD
student into this lab then he went
actually to Teri's lab and now he's at
Nirvana Intel relevant versed a mouse or
a cat for this is yeah this is a cat and
actually the data I will show you are
from cat but Judas does now similar
experiments also in ferret so very
visual animals without any doubt and
mice with some people but we have hold
them very good evidence that mice are
visual - so she does now also study
other species but this is cat and so
basically what you can do with this data
is you can do something like spikes
although you can really detect these
these little these these uh prizes here
in and there are puta puta Tiff's epsp
so these are the synaptic inputs to that
cell and they are really big in the in
in the real a cell in a
McCree little they are so big that you
can even measure the them extra servo
Wally this is the so-called s potentials
discovered by a planet I'll in the 80s
and this is also this makes this very
interesting so potentially one could
actually really scale up these studies
now using some volt voltage dye methods
also so for that reason I think this is
very interesting but in this case we
just listen to one cell these are the
outputs so that we listen to the red
cell and the red spikes here are the
output spikes and the blue spikes are
the input spikes and now of course one
can just do ya and so now I'm what I
also want to do is so it's it's similar
to a Chris first and told us yesterday
you listen to two subsequent stages in
the feed forward path of of visual
processing but here this is an earlier
stage this is basically the output from
the retina to this first way station
which is the LGN and in the the
receptive fields as we already hold are
kind of centers around receptive fields
like Coulomb reported in the in the 50s
and then there's also a temple coma and
so if you so this is a basic x code
comes like this so you have kind of heal
a temple kernel and you have a very
small receptive field which has stories
read our centers around structure and so
you can now use the property that it's
pretty localized inspiration time to
actually to estimate the mutual
information between a stimulus and a
spike by saying okay what I need to know
about the stimulus is basically just the
projection so as of T is the stimulus a
time a projection operator B onto this
relevant subspace of the of the cell and
then you basically can practice in a
formula that was proposed actually by by
V Alex group a long time ago and you can
actually measure the the mutual
information of the information rate in
in for example bit spa spike now if you
just do that
independently on the input and the
output and you see and many people
reported that in the early 2000s you
basically see that the the information
content in the LGN spike is higher than
the retinal spike train and this also
the main reason for that is that the
rate is much lower in the LGN because of
course there's the information
processing in inequality so the
information can only go down and so
basically what gene did now is that he
he determined just using white noise
stimuli and so on he determined that the
relevant subspace it's in the stimulus
space and then he actually compared them
and so basically this is now just
vectors in the directions of these
receptive fields and so the again the
convention here is input is blue output
is red and so you can see in this this
is just a cartoon example but here they
they are not exactly the same and so you
can basically now project the kind of
thing the the output feature on to the
input feature and you get basically a
feature which is a a gain feature so
there seems to be something encoded
about the input the visual input in the
output which is not encoded in the input
which is strange and I will resolve this
but and so you can now basically model
the spike drains you by decomposing the
stimulus features of the Chow and pre
and postsynaptic space and and then for
example constructing Ellen LNP models so
here you have just a linear receptive
field you have maybe a non-linearity and
some spiking mechanism and so what comes
out from this is actually that just
champion today so so so so so if you
just stimulate with a Gaussian ensemble
white noise stimulus this the black and
scent of cloud here is the unconditional
stimulus
and you can all see that the conditional
stimulus the conditional stimulus
distribution conditioned on either the
input in blue or the output on red is
now as somebody flick loud and it's also
the red in the blue do not coincide so
they also somehow different yet so
there's something I don't quite
understand so there's only one input to
this dynamic cell from the restaurant
yes so well we do not really do cell
sorting so it's basically all the
detectable inputs but these are not only
these unitary inputs that we can really
detect so there there are some other
effects for example inhibitory effects
on the on the cell that's true and there
are not so you cannot detect in a real a
cell ipsp absolutely so exactly so so so
this is not necessarily a spike train
from just one cell but very often it is
so it depends a little bit we can try to
do clustering of these whole cell
intracellular blips and sometimes there
is a clear distinction sometimes it's
not that clear but these this is this is
a set of cells where there was kind of
one dominant input but it's not
guaranteed we don't have a guarantee
that it's just one yeah so this is
actually for for yeah for measuring the
spatial properties he designed this is
kind of also Gaussian in the in the gray
level space but it's it's kind of taking
into account that we know it's more or
less centers around but what's important
here is that the change in the feature
and the coding feature that you see is
is the bigger difference between input
and output is actually in the temporal
in this in the in the temple so that the
correlation between the temple input and
output shape is much smaller so this is
now averaged over the cell population of
the 15 or 20 cells that they actually
examined and the spatial receptive
fields are very similar and this
actually led people to say oh yeah
I mean the LGN is just a passive relay
nothing happens there but it does happen
something here actually in the temple :
you can see that the the output Colonel
becomes longer in time so more more
memory and more biphasic I shouldn't
comment yeah you asked that question
about what two or three everyone who
hears about connectomics
should know about the beginning of
mammalian connectomics which is this man
here in 1983
almost Raj Cascadian sherman studying
that problem reading it's beautiful
the feature by definition should
shouldn't be absent in the presynaptic
signal yeah and it pretty much is I mean
the main shift here I mean it's it's
getting a little bit elongated so in the
second moment something is happening but
it's mainly shifting on this blue line
and in the and the red is kind of he'll
deviating about going going in this
direction it's hard to see but there
should be this ourselves
no no this this is this is that the
stimulus this is the spike-triggered
stimulus ensemble so basically every
time there was a stimulus that triggered
a spike this gives a dot okay one cell
one song one song okay but yeah let's
let's not I just let me get through that
so what you can do now in this in this
plane of the of the presynaptic feature
in the gain feature you can now
basically also ask what is the what is
the information in different directions
here on this plane and you get these
dumbbell shape curve and you can see
that is this tilt from the input to the
output and you can also see that is
there is this there is these sectors
that are white where you actually
where the information rate goes up but
but then Nels also the black section
actually the the information rate goes
down and so this is of and so I mean the
the biggest the biggest puzzle is okay
well this information coming from the
information processing inequality is
violated here were some information
about this game feature in the output
which is not in the input and and so now
the resolution of the puzzle is actually
to look into the higher order structure
of the spike train so the next step is
kind of to ask the question what is
actually the code what is the language
there's very little feedback does I mean
this is an anesthetized animal and of
course there's a lot of feedback
synapses as we know from the anatomy but
they are hard to see in the physiology
so all the hallmarks of these unitary
epsps that we can trust on was salt
they have retinal ganglion cell gang of
the hallmarks so they look like five
petals of red retinal ganglion cells so
this is you can think of this as a feed
forward path and okay and so that the
symmetry is not basically the question
if you compute what's the information in
a enough spike pair of a certain latency
is this just two times the single spike
information or is it more if it's more
we say it's positive synergy if it's
less it's it's it's kind of a redundancy
in the code and so this is now basically
showing you the synergy as a function of
this interspike interval and you can see
in the output it's pretty flat so
there's no energy this is a single spike
code but in the input you see actually
for small agencies you see that there is
a significant synergy in this this the
now various many all the 20 cells also
you see it's a lot of the most of the
cells are hidden behind the mean red
line but in the inputs you see there
there is significant synergy
and what you cannot do is you can ask
okay
is there a transformation happening
maybe in this in this neuron that
actually takes show up is eyes and
transforms them into a single spike and
does this actually account for this game
feature and the answer's yes
and so basically that you can set up a
model where you say okay I have the
Nylund model is just of a model value
value assumed of the firing probability
is independent of the previous ayahs I
but then you can actually fit a model to
to the spike train of the cell that
really has here this increase for short
is is and you can now basically model
the the observed p ps t HS and so you
can now see you can now compare this
model that actually has this effect this
is called a paired spike facilitation
has been reported by marty a sri and
others so this is definitely something
that people have seen before we see it
here on this one particular cell and and
fit it but if you now actually look in
how well you can fit the PS th responses
of these cells so this is time and this
is basically trust the psdh size here on
the y-axis you can see that the nile
model so that the blued data is the the
blue is the real data in the red is the
models no sorry the and so here is the
model here's the here's the true data
and here's the nile model and here is
actually the eyes i'm only you can
already see that the isi modulated spy
spiking mechanism actually does a much
better job in reproducing here the the
red line above yes
so that's an extremely sharp transition
that seal their CEO interest I get your
point
are there any ideas what physiologically
could cause that calcium in the
presynaptic terminal you've no a synapse
II cannot have 0 if I can refer them to
you but flat flat is the baseline
flenders de yeah yeah so no before zero
just the baseline so it's gonna be flat
and then immediately afterwards its
person epic summation was yeah but you
know this is 50 milliseconds he also the
resolution here what happens at 0 and 1
milliseconds i as i yes they'll is you
know in a lot of these of these patrick
holdings we do see really the refractory
period also of so but not always in this
is then when we assume there's more than
one input so how long does it go down 0
see it's yeah I think you know the spy
grades are so thick we could not relieve
yeah it's it's interesting okay anyway
but let me wrap this the story up so so
basically what we can really do is kind
of also reproduce these information
plots and we can be kind of it if you
put this help spike facilitation model
and you see the stilled of the red
dumbbell and you can also you can
basically so now let me just go to that
slide so basically what you can see is
that in the
so this is data versus the denial model
and so you can see that the data has
actually higher information rate than
then the nine model but you can see if
you actually use this pal spike
facilitation model you come closer here
to to the identity line so so it's no
it's still not a full full explanation
of everything so it's still a
systematically a little bit below but it
follows the line pretty well so let me
just sum sum that up so a little idea of
what the LGN does is really a relay that
relays actively this information but
does not change very much the language
or the content and what we can see is
really that first the language is
changed so the RTC spike trains are
synergistic I can't tell you why but
that you have to to kind of separate if
you if you want to decode the code you
have to separate shawl tire size from
single spikes to do the best job and the
LGN spike trains in contrast are
entirely single spike and of course this
makes a lot of sense if you thinks that
I think that LGN spikes now are
integrated like what clay described to
us in subfields or simple cells you
don't want to require a mechanism that
tells a partial tire size from single
spikes you just want to sum up so it
makes sense that each signal tree is
there you want to remove it before you
start really to integrate and build more
complicated receptive fields so this is
wasteful to means you have redundant
spike yes that's right yeah because yeah
yeah yeah it's a it's a good question
but you know there is more to the story
I will not go into this but there there
is also ongoing activity in the retina
is periodic activity in the retina and
so this is not the entire story so I I
just give you this as an example how you
can actually if you are able to recall
off from subsequent stages you can tease
apart these two questions how does the
language change and how does the feature
change
and I think that is a very interesting
application of just shining info
information with some sort of error
correction if you're young so Fritzi if
you go to the next step a lot to b1 then
there are there are dozens of papers on
the time period you were talking about
before in the heyday of information
theory like Lance often very rich man
all those people a and they computed the
information content in different spikes
and of course the most was in the first
spike of of a short sequence but there
was non-trivial information in the
second and if memory serves correctly
even some in the third and then after
that there wasn't much information so so
there's something of a difference in v1
at least by having two maybe three
spikes as opposed to one well okay so
there's another I also we also have
stories there's actually also boasts I'm
not talking here about pills cells burst
in retina in tears burst in the in DL
Jian in to elicit them and of course
Murray has all the the only data is from
Mary on on that and also he has theories
on that that this is something like
could be a wake-up call because usually
you need at least a DN activation of
calcium channels to actually get the
Boston energy and so the idea could be
if after a long period of kind of no
stimulation stimulus comes in posting is
actually a pulsed and it's actually very
interesting also in terms of
communication if you deal with
asynchronous communication you might
have signals like wake-up calls
handshake in India might of you might
actually you know efference copies and
all these things because it's not clear
it's an asynchronous parallel computing
system so stuff might need to be
communicated that you just do not think
about but yeah so there's more to this I
let me leave it by that right now and
just move on because
which yup if you kind of ignored because
the produces first right that's right
so okay so we also in actually seen also
the beautiful Studies on that and so
that one minute answer to this is you
see and on that naturalistic stimulation
you do see posts they come quite
consistently because it's in these
because you have this one over AB
structural temporally also in natural
scenes so you for a long time
often a receptive field is not
stimulated and then it gets stimulated
these are the instances where you
reproduce ibly kept the bursts they are
relatively rare most of them but you
know more than 90% of the spikes are
single spikes but there are filed at
pretty consistent temporal locations in
in in natural stimuli which is very
interested and then I mean Sheen went on
and study really does Takei Co mechanism
in detail because he had so wholesale
recordings and as we look at inhibition
that you cannot detect by just doing
these unitary event detection things we
try to reconstruct that and really
figure out also what's what's the
mechanism of inhibition that actually
have them is important for this
inactivation mechanism so sociological
Ollie's also interesting given the theme
that we've had we've heard that he's not
working for a hardware company is
building deep learning chips right yeah
but I have to put the alternate
hypothesis on the table at every follow
the evidence for the cards suggests that
they're to answer a very specific
question that's known before the secod
Lander and so an alternate way of
thinking about this is that in the
cortex there are multiple processes
competing to read the thalamus and so
basically there it's more like a a
polling mechanism for these things and
so rather as opposed to this beat
forward account where you're just trying
to preserve the innovation
yeah if you I mean if you look into the
data in the physiology to see the
feedback is not easy I mean there's
beautiful well thought by Ferran
Indumati ah sri who studied that or the
monkey it's it's very tricky to see the
feedback also we know of the anatomical
feedback to to the LGN that's the full
station well you actually have really no
fibers going back there's nothing going
back to the to the retinopathy is to lgn
and it's by the bat it's actually as a
neurophysiologist you are hard pressed
to see much of much evidence for the
spot of light you know that might not be
the right right
absolutely and all the data I have been
talking about was anesthetized cat but I
mean Ferran studied a vague monkey just
point out the you've written one of the
seminal papers that shows that the
oscillations in the retina are in the
face with the polemic yeah but this is
not a feedback mechanism I will not talk
about this I will not talk about this
now let's move on but actually you know
you're saying that these feedback
projections have weak or influence
that's not true but when the animal
falls asleep what happens is they
ourselves hyperpolarized and then Chris
actually dominated yes so insane state
changes definitely yeah yeah but am i
doing the visual if you just doing
visuals I think this is something it
really is confusing in the literature
because brain states change even in the
awake state right I mean we have
different levels of activation that's
right
and this is exactly a beautiful
transition to the next stage which is
really more about brain States and so
and this is actually both with Daniel
toca who is here on the audience
it also Hana who contributed the slide
will come up later but so the idea is
other information national stage
we can in a meaningful way apply to just
recordings of reactivity in recurrent
networks and there were early proposals
mainly in this context of consciousness
so there was Tony Oni who had several
proposals how to measure integrate
information they were then well somewhat
controversial because they were all not
always positive that this problem and
also very hard to estimate for reasons
just in terms of computational issues
and I will bring that up in but
sunni-shia Mari and in Sumy they
actually came up in recent PNAS paper
2016 with a pretty good definition and
this kind of involves that the geometric
integrate that geometric info
information geometry somehow and so let
me just explain that diagrams here this
you know do you Mars Emory no no it's
not it's no it's not a Mari I I made
this for a talk in the plane so I had
just to draw things and then
photographic so now it's no dice which
they would have these stamps you know of
Amaury lab 1968 also but no you know
like the harmonica hydro no good that I
could have faked them maybe yeah yeah so
I mean yeah you're all familiar how you
can kind of unfold dynamics that goes on
in a recurrent Network like what people
do also in deep learning if they want to
train recurrent networks and and so
basically now you can ask how
information travels through time and so
you can look at two times steps t minus
tau and T and you can basically just
measure the mutual information all you
can also partition the nodes first and
then measure the mutual information and
then you have basically all these
information flows between the partitions
within the partitions but now the idea
is
you come up with an iron model that cuts
these between partition information
flows and so basically you measure the
cool backlight of the options between
this model which is the full Kinect
connected model fully connected with
kind of the CAD model and this actually
turns out to be a bounded by mutual
information positives beautiful a lot of
really features that we like and and
this is what you are going to use and so
but now there's one problem I mean of
course you for every partition it spits
out a number that's a lot of numbers if
you have a bigger network whether you
have a lot can have a lot of partitions
a MB and so what to new Tony only
proposed is basically well let's just
focus on this one number which is the
minimal information partition so so you
you measure all the numbers and of this
of this integrated information and now
you take the minimum and the problem is
there's a lot of numbers to compute and
so this basically kept people from going
beyond toilet also stopped Christophe
clock so the proposal that that Daniel
came up is is basically say okay let's
do what people very often do in imaging
they and somehow connects also to the
the clickers kata so he did this for
spatial pattern but let's just look at
correlations but now between time causes
so let's come up with a matrix value all
the nodes in your network you you have
now kind of a hero correlation matrix of
the or just a temporal correlations of
the time calls and yeah and then
basically just apply of spectral
clustering and come up kind of with a
community clustering in in in this
network and so the idea is now I mean so
one hope could have been okay okay we
just look for the best community
clustering of the thing and this already
is the minimal
Meishan partitions it's not quite as as
simple but it turns out that and he
tested this in many different ways that
actually you can restrict the self space
enormous li and you find you basically
find a very good estimate fall for the
minimum information partition and then
basically a number for the integrated
information but what that now means is
basically that you're looking in your
network of nodes between you you look
for the V above that the vehicles
connected community partition and then
you ask what's what's the information
flow in and again the information from
the following sense it's kind of the the
if you if you measure information how
information emotion is propagated by the
network through time you ask how much do
the between connections contribute so if
you cut them how much lower is the
information okay so and now we are
basically ready so now the beauty of
this is you can now do this in networks
of hundreds and thousands of nodes
basically and so now it's time to really
come up with some some networks that you
can test this and this is then where our
friend first law comes comes in so so we
we actually so what what Daniel did is
actually he he's he's similar he kind of
had a construction process that used use
kind of some some heavy and wiring
mechanisms to come up with networks that
have some properties of connect homes
and then on the nodes we basically he
used was louis ladles so it's coupled
was lost later on network and the beauty
of the world louis dillais the network
is that there are well-known parameter
regimes where the data is pretty
gaussian unfortunately we had to do a
tour to kind of really adhere to to
Terry's prayer that things are Gaussian
because in order to estimate integrate
information that was involved of course
we are now working also on
methods that that actually can can do
without but so now this this just shows
some controls this show is now for
smaller networks of 14 and 16 networks
and 18 networks where he could still
compute brute force the minimal
information partition that you actually
get exactly if you subtract from from
the estimated minimal information
partition Phi the actual ground truth
one you get exactly zero and also the R
and index so you get exactly the right
petitions then he looked at large for
networks again it's it's a control it
doesn't work that it does not work
entirely perfectly but also pretty good
so so he'll he now introduced a cut by
hand so he again knew the ground truth
and so you could basically now also see
how things now for lots of networks used
you you you see that some of the value
is actually deviate but so this was kind
of an adult test and and now you can for
example you can now ask well in small
both networks were in the Strogatz
networks where you have this this random
so you start here with it just locally
connected ring and then you introduce
these cross-cutting connections here
with the probability P you can basically
ask what you know how is there the
geometric in from integrate information
going up and you see actually how it
goes up and then actually kind of
plateaus here once you have reached a
certain global connectivity level now
the most interesting question is how
this is actually really apply on data
and the beauty on this is you don't need
to know the craft you only need the time
series so basically if I give you the
time series you can kind of apply the
measure and determine what's the minimal
information by partition and in what is
actually minimal what is the integrate
information and and so this is now a
Koch data of monkey so it's it's it's
it's
HemisFair of monkey and and so this
shows you now so these are basically all
the electrodes and this shows you
basically that the result that you just
get if you do not eve spectral
clustering on the functional
connectivity matrix on this correlation
matrix so that's not very informative
but then if you really look for the
minimum information by partition you can
actually get in the two monkeys these
pedals and they of course really make
sense so it really splits here the
posterior since or since or areas from
the until association areas and so this
is basically the this is kind of and I
mean Daniel is now applying this to to
really understand brain states
differences how they actually express
express in this measure of integrate
information many other things but this
was kind of an encouraging first result
that he got why is it the two monkeys
are so different in terms of the
quantitative picture yeah that's
interesting yeah it's we don't know we
don't know it seems very consistent in
terms that these are contiguous areas
but yeah definitely it's I mean they're
also both of them somehow contain here
some temporal lobe I mean yeah but this
is all interesting and one cannot
studied I don't have the answers for
this right now
yeah absolutely you can use this like a
surgery knife basically now so you could
you can now go on and do this more yes
exactly so you can now look for
petitions within partitions and things
like that okay so now but now this is
basically just from functional data but
how what can we actually doing how can
we do kind of I would not say structural
function relationships but maybe
structural dynamic relationships how can
we study that wasn't this is actually
something that we started so involve
Kurt or had his first collection of the
cocoa mark data we actually did a study
and this is actually how we presented
this on a at a post or in 1997 so this
was basically the cocoa map database and
then we put very simple threshold
elements on the nodes and there are some
old studies than the 50s where they
stimulated with strychnine some were in
in the monkey cortex an area and then
they just made a list of the areas that
went active and so what we could show is
indeed if you use the full Cormac data
it is better than a nearest just the
nearest neighbor connection and
connectivity you can reproduce these
pedals that these guys so and the 50s
much better but no one was really
interested in these data of the 50s
because those were very rough data in a
way and so but now and this is actually
the the slide that Hannah contributed
who is here in is a Simon's research
fellow and she is an applied
mathematician at University of
Washington and and so basically what she
is now doing is basically using the
Allen mouse brain connectivity atlas and
again putting of dynamic dynamic
elements on on the nodes in this case
was lot of the ladles and now you
basically can run simulations in this
and I just put this
we put this in because you can now touch
yourself and this so this is now just
watch lois dillais there's no delays it
uses the real basically this connector
matrix and you can now church whether
you see traveling waves or not so we are
not so sure it's definitely not exactly
looking like what we saw from teri but
there's something
you know time glaze would be make it
more interesting yep
and bye honey that Henry Kennedy had a
much more accurate billing connectome
yes yes yeah yep any more connections in
yeah this is interesting how the Henry
Kennedy kornek toll now changes the
picture that we had from Kokomo
okay so so this it was a first foray in
how can you actually just compute a
number for a recurrent Network and there
are still a lot of holes to fill in
methodologically and also how to
interpret this but I think the the
channel capacity in feed-forward
pathways soft us very well we should
think about such measures we should
explore them and I think now actually
the infor information theory is in place
for for actually solid measures that
fulfill all the necessary requirements
to do that and but of course as
estimating information is always
difficult so there are still a lot of
issues to actually address and resolve
okay
so this kind of finishes up the
information okay so this finishes up
what I want to say about information
theory now let's get to this hypothesis
how cortical cortical communication
could actually take place under wiring
constraints so the question is now if it
seems you know 50% of the volume of the
brain roughly speaking is white metal in
but this is far from every connecting
every neuron with every other neuron so
they seem to be very hard wiring
constraints on cortical cultural
communication if actually these
connections between areas are actually
sparse rather than tens like what we are
use now in the deep learning networks
how would this actually change the
picture in how could you actually still
communicate high dimensional local
patterns through such type of
attractions that's the question and yeah
so this is a this vlog of guy Charles
the Alcott's
red would send or increase hello a
former postdoc and so how many people
here are familiar with compressed
sensing okay so let me just give a two
minutes version of it so if you want to
compress an image like this image how
many people recognize who is on that
image so I mean yes so you can do it
this way but it might not be the
smartest way so so you can just make the
pixels bigger which kind of reduces the
high frequency content but another way
which was proposed in the early - in
2006 it's compressed sampling or
compressed sensing and so the idea is
you basically just multiply this image
with with random projections and not so
many just n numbers like like these n
calls voxels over there and this gives
you an entirely garbled vector but what
you can do with this vector under the
assumption that there is some sparse
fiying basis for these images and it
turns out that's a reasonable assumption
you can actually solve a lasso problem
so basically what you can do is you
produce this garbled Y vector and now
you solve a lots of problem of this sort
so you you ask what is the best path
vector so that basically multiplied
actually with the specifying dictionary
for images I call this side in in the
end multiplied with the sensing matrix
it actually equals thus just compressed
vector as good as possible and then you
put as an l1 sparsity constraint on on
the sparse on the sparse vector here so
that's you can do that you can extra use
this optimization to extract the sparse
vector and then you just multiply it
with the dictionary and this gives you a
reconstruction of the image so that's
kind of the idea
so in other words you can use structure
in the high dimensional space which is
now not a dimensionality constrained but
it is a constrained in terms of sparsity
so that is that is the original idea and
note here that the receiver needs to
know the sensing matrix and now if you
think about a cultic of cortical
communication so you have two regions
here that one has in the superficial
layers neurons that would check to
another region here yeah so there's the
cost there's a cost of encoding and
decoding and that's true you know at all
of information theory you know the
modern codes are very computation
intensive but they're better in terms of
reaching the Shannon limit yeah yeah and
if you look at your new scheme right
you're pushing a lot of the computation
into the decoding stuff absolutely
exactly yeah and so now how do we model
this so yeah the idea is now that these
neurons basically just subsample the
high-dimensional so the idea is that
there is lots of local neurons here and
and that these neurons with help
dendritic trees subsample these local
and reverse pass response petals think
of this off as v1 for example and so
this is basically the matrix a here and
then this is sensor the wiring
bottleneck to a receiver region and then
basically what the receiver region needs
to do is to do exactly what I just
extractor you it it has to source this
LF there's this lasso problem the
problem is of course you cannot expect
that there's this sampling matrix which
describes how the dendritic arbors here
connect to the local neurons is somehow
known by this receiver region so you
need kind of a learning to do that and
so this is basically now a dictionary
problem and the question is and what
condition can a receive a region which
is trust bombarded with compressed
signals long a B matrix that actually
allow us to produce Hills pass vectors P
that are by some
reasonable similarity metric similar to
the to the to the a vector he'll yeah
have a fundamentals question here so if
if i understand what we need to
reconstruct basically if you know from
the theory that you've passing they're
relevant all the information you need
downstream you yeah yeah right so so so
i would not say it's reconstruction it's
basically so you are compressing
information so basically one fiber he'll
contains information about many
different features and it's more
disentanglement than a reconstruction so
so what I am saying is so how this
hypothesis sees of communication in
cortex is that you go through this
expansion and compression stages in but
you shouldn't think about this as a as a
reconstruction but it's getting access
to the features that are mixed together
in these in the in the dense
representations that's the way so okay
so so basically what we examined with
with Chris now was okay under what
conditions so we know the conditions of
compressed sensing so you know that if
you have a certain number of if
basically your spouse vectors have a
certain dimension and your sparsity
let's just say this is now an l0
sparsity the number of nonzero elements
has a certain number then we can kind of
we know that then the dimension of the
compressed vector goes like the
logarithm of these of the ratio of these
two numbers over the sequence and this
is kind of an auto one constant so it so
the good news is here you can really
compress so M can be of much higher
dimension than actually Y but the
question is now and the what conditions
can you do the learning and so basically
what we showed in this paper is that
under exactly the same condition so
whenever you can do compress sensing you
also can do this learning so so so what
that means is you you just you have a
the region who is entirely agnostic
about the sampling matrix and it is able
up to a permutation to actually learn of
the sampling matrix in the lasso problem
so that actually the be that the
reconstructed sparse vectors are up to a
permutation and in a linear stretch the
same as the sparse vectors in the sender
region and and so this is basically just
a demonstration of this where we did
kind of devoid computation so think of
this as three brain areas and all they
did here is we started to so that we
trained this with image patches so the
first is a sparse coding model basically
and then we basically just compress the
sparse codes do here the learning
compress and do the learning and you can
kind of see in this void computation of
course the features look all similar
because nothing happens but of course
what what what we left out to you is the
local computation that happens and but
of course the premise here is that
whatever the local computation does
there is instill a sparse structure
otherwise this this scheme would not
work so to sum this up and it's it's a
hypothesis how you could do
communication under wiring constraints
we showed that basically whenever
compressed sensing rocks or the
dictionary learning course you can do
this it kind of makes the assumption
that the input stages of cortical
regions to something like sparse coding
so it's very compact compatible with the
sparse coding hypothesis and again the
the overall picture is that the
communication might be might include
this expansion and compression
alternation in somehow this Valk and
this brings me to my my last point this
word inspire us now to say well if you
if if we now assume the brain could do
this with with what is sent through
these fiber projections of causing LF
piece you should also be able to do this
and even in challenging cases in cases
where you don't have a topic graphic
organizations of the feed
so LFP decoding is quite well blocks
quite well and is well understood if you
have orientation columns or something
like that because what the local field
potential does it sums up signals from
from many cells in the vicinity of your
electrode and it kind of mixes all these
signals together but if these signals
kind of tell you something about a very
similar feature no problem you will get
an orientation selectivity of your
entire electrode and you're done
but in the hippocampus this is different
the hippocampus we know that in a
particular environment place cells are
salt and pepper source also nearby
Blazers are not represented nearby by
place else at all nearby and so now let
me just so this is joint work with if
what you say is true it should be
possible for you to take one of these
dance recordings and extract what the
you know right you call it a dictionary
but you know whatever it is that was
being bless encoding that have you tried
it we didn't because the data I mean you
would really need you would have you'd
need two recordings from identified
neurons I mean it's a little bit what
Christiano yes that is you said we could
start to look in data of this type right
so so you you're saying you think that
you're mainly recording from the output
neurons and so that but we didn't do
that but that would be now the test
that's exactly what needs to be done
okay so just briefly the hippocampus a
structural deep in the brain often in
the hierarchy picture on the top of the
hierarchy for example of sensory systems
also deep in the brain but yet if you
are in a certain environment you have
these cells that that actually represent
certain locations certain places in an
environment in addition but you also
have in Terry already showed some
pictures you have kind of very strong 10
Hertz oscillations in this behave all
state where the animal is is navigating
actively through the environment in
actually the place cells really
represent the places where the animal is
right now rather than doing replay kind
of mental traveling and it has been
known that actually if you recall not
only spike trains of such play cells but
also the the face of the load of this 10
horse teed up postulation that there is
this face possession structure which
means you get a little bit of super
resolution so if you are that the the
red neuron starts to fire here it starts
out later in the face of the Theda
oscillation and as the animal travels
travels as the place fill it gets to
somewhat earlier points and so you if
you recall from both you get a little
bit hippocampus yourself so still debate
whether this is used by the animal
because you have so many play cells you
might not need it so it's it's but it's
an interesting observation and basically
what we ask now and of is yeah and so
the problem of course with reading out
now from the local field potential a
place information is that is that this
is the picture so if you are somewhere
with your electrode you kind of recall
signals from currents or in the
dendritic trees around you but these
belong to play cells that encode very
different places and so therefore the
the entire place selectively
of your entire LFP electrode is pretty
flat and it's it's actually hard to
decode all you cannot really decode it
so eureka sake recorded you know l FPS
along the hippocampus and was able to
decode location using ica right with
that paper yeah but i mean what i will
show you it's basically so that's all
exactly what we do here too but what we
now use is and so the question is now if
you just filter over ten halt signals
that you recall from multi from a multi
electrode array placed in c1 c3 of
cortex and you filter 10 holes so you
you removed information that you would
need to spike salting or detect even
gamma activity can you use the can you
use this multi valued signal to actually
code value at the anomalies and the
answer is yes and so very briefly what
you need to do for that is basically to
first characterized using just principal
component analysis the the traveling
wave structure so this is now just the
electrode array here on the x-axis
dissolved now just the 10 holes filled
up signals basically just displayed over
time and so you see this is this
traveling wave that you you have in the
hippocampus and what we do we actually
used is traveling wave as a carrier and
then detect phase distortions with
respect to that carrier and it turns out
that actually this this signal contains
you can then decode the location of the
animal and so this this just using
basically linear decoding and so this
this is basically the decoding so here
you see the the continuous line is where
the animal walks so this is just a
lynnium a linear may a linear track and
as time evolves here on the x axis the
animal goes back and forth
okay and the continuous line is where
the animal is and the tottered lines is
where the linear decoder thinks the
animal is and you can see you can do
this with if you do spike solving and
use the spike signals and you can also
do this actually using these face
distortions in the LFP actually if you
combine both you can even do better it's
also interesting that actually if you if
you trust PCA a dimensionality reduction
using PCA the the variance here goes
down much more quickly than actually the
decoding performance so there's
definitely something in these signals
which is not entirely captured by PCA
and so for that reason we we applied ICA
on on these face distortions and so it's
complex ICA and so here's what you get
so so so this is the animal moving in
one direction and this is in the above
direction and then if you just look on
these panels so each color here is a
different independent component in in
this face distortions multivariate phase
distortion signal and it is when the
coefficient is high so so and here on
the y axis are trials so you can see
very consistently the light blue guy
goes on here and then the dark blue guys
goes on and so on and you have also a
tiling you have for every location
basically in the maze you you have a you
have you have an independent component
and you have one set of components that
actually tile walking to the right and
one walking to the left and and the nice
thing is now that this is a so this is
also a very robust signal so you can
actually just leave out randomly about
50% off to your electrodes if even if
the electrodes would move probably so
it's a it's a very robust signal also
for doing actually brain brain machine
interface and and so how do they do
actually these phase distortion pedals
look in the grid space they are very
distributed so you really need so
there's no localization in the
hippocampus but there are basic
reproduce reproducible phase distortion
patterns as the animal visits the same
that the same location again and you can
actually you can read that signal out
and it this also works in more
complicated environment so he'll
different I CAS again are marked by
different colors this is kind of in a
resting area he'll small kind of 2d area
where you can also see there seems to be
some fine structure in here so to sum up
and to finish so these the interesting
thing is that these waves seem not to
not only indicate brain states of the
animal but they see that if you if you
know how to look at their structure they
tell you detailed behavioral information
and the interesting thing is not only
this now could help us now we have two
different ways to do the decoding and it
could help us to really understand what
is computed locally in the circuit but
there's also very nice evidence actually
Joni Wallace gave a talk at cosine two a
week a week ago also and she reported
that if she does actually
decision-making experiments with with
actually visual stimuli to monkeys that
have actually different values assigned
to different faces the the monkey learns
how to choose the highest-valued face
very very good and in prefrontal cortex
a few neurons that encode that while
this computation is going on she sees
actually theta oscillations in
hippocampus and prefrontal cortex
coherent and she recalls now actually
from these post structures and will be
very interesting to see whether some of
this traveling wave structure actually
has to do with the long-range
communication so that finishes my talk
this is the funding thank you and happy
to take questions
[Applause]
so a compress sensing part of your talk
there was the there's been a lot of
interest in the off factory system
because there it looks like the piriform
cortex which by the way has the same
same architecture is the hippocampus for
me
it looks very much as if you go from a
very you know with each receptor one
type of receptor for each glomerulus in
the olfactory bulb projects very broadly
and seems to you know the single
parameter so I'm seems to be sampling
from any groom Airlines the same time it
looks there like that might be another
place where you're doing this to throw
down some competing theories who even
which even do not need that sort so the
idea is that you can actually now
construct random separation planes in
this justice expanded space without
doing anything and even relying on any
structure you know you can think of
sparse coding as being an auto encode or
going up and down this is one way to
think about of course if you don't want
to think about ordering codels going up
the hierarchy because and you know as
what said before we don't want
reconstruction of the same thing but
sparse coding absolutely is you can you
can do sparse coding as an outer our
auto encoder where you put not I mean
not a limitation and the dimensionality
on the latent representation in the
outer encoder but sparsity but there's
basically you know it does a
reconstruction objective like in Coto
so put this you ever thought of it it's
on the information geometry you
mentioned the amore definition of
distance to be independent independence
manifold and did you ever actually use
that well I actually no we we use a
Maris definition of integrated
information
geometric integrated information and
this uses it and the funny thing is
before people thought I mean there's a
very similar measure proposed by Neha
Diane is called stochastic interaction
but it's not the same so it's really
interesting if you think in terms of
information geometry about integrated
information it helps you to really tease
out what what you're talking about what
you want to quantify so the graph cut
stuff no not no not not directly the
graph cuts stuff was really I mean just
taking this this correlation matrices
and then detecting community communities
in them that was not because you could
you could think in geometric terms of
finding some segmentation of the space
do something composition of the space in
which the information for that the
independence manifold was embedded there
is a theory this year actually take the
Texas multi-information which is really
not your side right yes between the
joint and and and the tooth the two sub
graphs and essentially we just force it
to minimize information and you get
these transitions to this connector
component just in the same way that
that's my business
and this actually we proposed it in the
minimum information principle yeah yep
right so I think correlation might not
be the best place to start because as
you know things to be correlated without
having any connectivity at all simply
with the joint input or some kind of
circulating latent variables yeah so I
mean if there's a huge literature
unfortunately it's called functional
connectivity in the moment yeah yeah
exactly yeah this is called functional
connectivity that they call these
correlation matrix it's functional
connectivity no I know it's crazy but
you know it's that's if that's the
convention okay live look but but it but
it turns out that the people have
actually gone beyond that I mean some
some small lots of groups and if you
take the inverse of the covariance
matrix to call the precision matrix you
can do better it's not ideal yeah yeah
yeah but you know you might want to take
that as you know if you see anything
different I mean I was surprised
actually how well they do like they
don't sound good yeah but you might be
able to actually get to get even deeper
yeah another question has to do with
yeah it works so well with theta but
maybe you know what about some of the
other frequency bands right we know
they're travelling waves theta this is
so I mean really so we're actually not
talking to Pascale Freese who actually
sees this face devil sateen gamma and so
we all now absolutely we are
yep they look at the travelling wave if
they didn't hippocampus on like the 2d
surface of campus right yeah what do you
think there might be anything on the
third dimension like going along the
dendritic access with their beam
traveling waves there I think actually
yeah I mean you will also see some I'm
not sure if it's a traveling wave but
you definitely see a phase shift size
you go to go down yeah yeah that just
has to do with the sine of the current
going it out right
I think it's the same way but I don't
think there's a yeah yeah I think so too
yeah yeah so it's mainly going across
the that's office
okay
[Applause]